Uruguay is a country famous for soccer.
As we celebrate Russia’s World Cup this
summer, we’ve checked the
hall of fame and there are only 8 countries
that have ever won a final.
Uruguay, a really small country
with little more than 3 million inhabitants is one of them.
They even won the cup twice and in both cases
they beat their neighbours: Brazil and Argentina.
So in today’s video, we’re gonna talk
about how Uruguay has beaten its neighbours
but not in soccer but
in economics instead.
Yes, my dear viewers, alongside Chile, Uruguay
is the wealthiest country in South America
GDP per capita
wise.
It’s also one of the most stable when it
comes to politics and has some of the best
public
services.
But there is even more to this.
We can actually say that Uruguay is the model
for the entire
South American left wing.
Have you ever heard about their former president,
JOSE MUJICA?
Known as the
‘World’s poorest president’, he quickly
became the ultimate left wing rockstar.
The only world leader who
refused to live in the presidential palace
and kept driving an old Volkswagen instead
of an expensive
official car.
“From a life philosophy perspective, I believe
it’s better to live with little luggage.
Just the minimum
necessary.
No material complexity.
If you have too many complexities… you end
up spending too much time.
Nonetheless, while Mujica had this simple
lifestyle, his country grew economically,
attracted foreign
companies and became a pioneer in social Rights.
With Mujica as president, Uruguay passed a
bill for the
legalization of same-sex marriage.
But, undoubtedly, his most famous policy was
the legalization of
recreational marijuana sales.
Way before California or any other place,
Uruguay was the first country to
legalize weed selling and consumption.
And the country’s progress doesn’t stop
there.
If you take a static picture of Uruguay, you
will see a
country that, arguably, is the best place
to live in all of South America.
Unlike Brazil and Argentina,
Uruguay’s economy hasn’t stopped growing
since 2002.
They have a thriving middle class and the
highest
wages in the region, along with Chile.
But wait a minute because not everything is
a field of roses!
In fact, as such a prosperous country, you
might expect it to have lots of immigrants,
right?
The reality is way different.
And this is not because
they have strong immigration laws.
People just don’t pick Uruguay as a country
of residence because…
well, things are starting to go sour here.
They have around an 8% unemployment rate and
their economy is
reducing their growth speed while other countries
like PERU and CHILE, seem to offer opportunities
for
everyone.
So today’s question is…
Why has Uruguay’s economy worked out so
well until now?
And what are the current
problems they’re facing?
Today we are going to answer to all of these
questions.
But before we do, let’s
take a look back at history.
AMERICAS’ SWITZERLAND
Uruguay was born in 1830 after a war between
BRAZIL and ARGENTINA.
The British were to negotiate the
peace agreements and they badly wanted Uruguay
to be an independent country.
Why?
Well, Montevideo’s
harbour was a jewel and they didn’t want
it to end up in Brazilian or Argentinian hands.
Back then, Uruguay was almost uninhabited.
It was inhabited by a tribe, the so called
CHARRUAS *CZECH
PRONOUNCE: ČARUAS* but they were soon exterminated.
This is why, unlike any other South American
country,
most of the Uruguayans have a European ethnicity,
mainly Spanish and Italian roots.
In those times, if you were an ambitious boy
looking for a career and opportunities to
make money,
Uruguay was the place to go.
Better than America or Australia.
It was a modern democracy with rule of law
and a thriving economy.
Until the 60s of the 20th century, this country
was among the wealthiest.
Way richer than many European
nations.
So now you might wonder…
What happened?
Because, despite being prosperous among the
South American
nations, Uruguay is still way behind any European
country, let alone America.
So what happened to make
them stop growing that dramatically?
The answer lies in… the EUROPEAN UNION!
Yes, you heard me right!
Listen, my dear viewers, if you thought
this idea of a trade war was Donald Trump’s
invention… you are very mistaken.
In the year 1958, the European Single Market
was created.
And one of the first things they did was
protect their agriculture from Uruguayan meat.
This meant that Uruguay lost one of its biggest
customers.
And America didn’t want to trade with them
either.
In the middle of the cold war, they were too
busy
dealing with bigger problems than this little
country.
So day by day, Uruguay became stagnant.
And the government in Montevideo, the country’s
capital, didn’t
have any other alternative than looking to
their neighbours: Argentina.
All of a sudden, Uruguay and
Argentina became something like the ROBERT
RODRIGUEZ and QUENTIN TARANTINO of South America.
Did
Argentina have a crisis?
So did Uruguay!
Did Argentina have a military dictatorship?
Did
Argentina have a democracy?
So did Uruguay!
So my dear viewers… what happened in Argentina
in the year 2002?
Exactly!
They had the biggest financial
crisis in history!
The infamous ‘CORRALITO’.
And in that very same year, Uruguay’s GDP
fell by 7.7%.
A
big time catastrophe.
And this was when Uruguay realized that it
had to find new trade Partners.
But how
do you do that?
We’ll see right now!
THE 0 KM OF SOUTH AMERICA
During the 80s, Uruguay returned to democracy.
And the government did something really, really,
interesting: they created the so called ZONAS
FRANCAS.
These were special territories inside of the
country where companies were free to not pay
taxes: no VAT, no income tax, no corporate
tax.
The only
request was that 75% of the jobs be given
to the locals.
Does that remind you of something?
Exactly!
This
is the same as the special economic zones
that the Chinese have and that we like so
much here at
VisualPolitik.
Today, Uruguay has 11 tax free zones.
And there are three different kinds.
First, we have those oriented
to logistics and international trade.
After that, we have the zones that are designed
for attracting
multinational corporations so they can use
them as the headquarters for their South American
operations.
Finally, we have the areas that are meant
to have high tech industry.
This is why Uruguay is a regional
leader in things like Pharma research and
software.
But this is not the end of the story!
These tax free zones have a unique advantage.
Something that makes
Uruguay a model for other countries.
Yes, dear viewers, we are talking about POLITICAL
stability.
Do you
think I’m kidding?
No way!
In the year 2005, Uruguay changed its government
leadership and they had, at last, a left wing
president.
That would be, of course, TABARE VAZQUEZ,
from the OPEN FRONT party.
You see, in most South American
countries, having such an ideological shift
in the government means that most of the work
made by the
previous administrations goes into the trash.
So you might think that, under a brand new
left government,
those tax free zones would no longer exist.
Right?
Well, the reality couldn’t be more different.
And this
is the great thing about this country: the
bipartisan consensus.
This is why, between 2005 and 2014, the
accumulated investment in these tax free zones
rose to almost 6000 million dollars.
And all of this
happened while, first, TABARE VAZQUEZ and
then JOSE MUJICA, managed the country.
“People are not only looking for profit.
They also want safety.
And this is what Uruguay has to offer.
It
is not a matter of this or the other Government.
This is a genuine Uruguayan attitude.
And now you might wonder…
What does Uruguay get from these tax free
zones?
Well, my dear viewers… there
is a double benefit for them.
On one hand, they are able to appeal to industries
that otherwise would set
up in other countries with bigger markets.
And these foreign companies need providers.
This is why,
sooner than expected, many small enterprises
are created around the country.
And, of course, they require
highly skilled labour and good salaries.
This is why Uruguayans don’t need to emigrate
in order to find a
good job.
But wait a moment here!
Because we said that Uruguay needed to change
their trade partners, right?
DO you
remember how we said that they could no longer
depend on Argentina or Brazil for their exports.
So you
might wonder… what do the tax free zones
have to do with all of this?
Well… think about it.
Thanks to
these innovative industries that set up in
the country, Uruguay could stop relying on
the commodity
sector.
Prior to this, their economy was based mainly
on Soy and Meat.
Now, they can create more added
value products.
Want an example?
All of the syrup needed in PEPSI drinks sold
all across South America is created in
Uruguay.
In fact, there is a popular drink in Japan
called PEPSI AZUKI.
This variety is made with a plant
called SWEET BEAN.
And, again, the syrup for this beverage is
produced 200km away from Montevideo.
In
total, Pepsi represents 7% of everything the
country exports.
And this is not the only example.
For example, one of the biggest paper making
companies on the planet, a
Finnish company called UPM, has one of their
main factories in Uruguay.
And, they have already announced
the construction of a brand new facility that
might represent a whole 2.5% extra GDP for
the country.
And if that isn’t enough, Uruguay is also
a software leader.
Eight Uruguay software developers, among the
best in all of Latin America
In summary, 30% of Uruguay’s exports are
produced from these tax free zones.
And guess who is the main
buyer!
Let me give you a clue!
It starts with CHI and ends with NA.
Nowadays, Brazil and Argentina
receive just 20% of this country’s exports.
Another good friend of Uruguay is the Netherlands.
The Rotterdam harbour is the gateway to Europe.
And
many of the Uruguayan exports go that way.
TO make a comparison, Chile’s economy, despite
being the
wealthiest in the region, is heavily reliant
on their copper mining.
Half of their exports are just this
commodity.
Uruguay, instead, has a very diversified economy:
we talked about software, paper, drinks and,
of course, soy and meat.
But if you thought everything is all sunshine
and flowers… then wait a minute!
Because things are not as perfect as you might
think.
PARTY vs GOVERNMENT
As we said before, since the year 2005, Uruguay
has a Left wing government.
More specifically, this
country has been managed by the OPEN FRONT
Party.
And… one thing is true, they are worthy
of that name,
because it is really an open party, with lots
of different ideologies inside.
This is why, despite what
it looks like, arguments are a common thing
in the party.
So, on one hand, despite the different presidents,
Uruguay has had the same finance minister
for the last
13 years.
His name is DANILO ASTORI, and you can say
he is one of the architects of this Uruguayan
stability.
But on the other hand, the OPEN FRONT is an
open battlefront between the radical wing
and the moderate
wing championed by TABARE VAZQUEZ.
JOSE MUJICA, the left wing rockstar, is somewhere
in the middle.
And this is why, anytime Uruguay´s government
wants to sign a free trade deal with any other
country,
they must face their own party opposition.
It happened during the first Vazquez administration,
when they
tried to sign a trade deal with the United
States.
It happened when they tried to sign a trade
deal with
Chile.
And it might happen now when they wanna sign
a trade deal with China.
“This year, 2018, will mark 30 years of
diplomatic relations with China and this is
why we have put this
date as a deadline to sign a free trade deal”
In this case, Uruguayan companies would save
more than 100 million dollars in Needless
tariffs.
But this
radical wing of the OPEN FRONT seems to be
allergic to the word “free trade”.
And if this was not enough,
some critics claim that DANILO ASTORI, the
finance minister, spends too little.
But this is precisely one of the biggest problems
in Uruguay.
After Venezuela and Argentina, Uruguay has
the biggest share of civil servants in the
region.
1 out of 5 workers is employed by the government.
Add
to this the enormous presence of the illegal
economy and you will understand why just a
third of all
Uruguayan adults work for private companies.
In most developed nations, this number is
more than half.
Of course, compared with ARGENTINA or BRAZIL,
Uruguay is a paradise on Earth.
But the truth is, if they
want to keep growing, they must solve these
problems ASAP.
So now the final question is…
Do you think Uruguay should sign those free
trade deals?
Do you think it is
still worth investing in this country?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
And of course, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM,
the podcast that provided the voices in this
episode that were
not mine.
And don´t forget to support us on Patreon,
where you will also get access to exclusive
content.
If you liked this video, please, give us a
thumbs up and, as always, I’ll see you next
time.